question s'adresser au ministre de
l'agriculture et faisait appel à sa
mémoire
avant d'être ministre il a été sénateur
est ici même en 2018 nous étions tous
favorables à la revalorisation des
retraites agricoles et ce dès 2018
contrairement à votre gouvernement nous
nous en souvenons bien puisque madame
agnès buzyn nous avait répondu que ce
point serait finalement intégré à la
réforme des retraites et que vous aviez
eu recours au vote bloqué une façon de
dire à la représentation nationale
terminé il n'ya rien à voir
et aujourd'hui à écouter le président de
la république
ce projet de réforme serez
révolutionnaire mais il n'en est rien
ceux qui atteindront les 1000 euros de
retraite ne représentent qu'un quart des
situations cette retraite minimum ne
sera en réalité que pour ceux ayant
cotisé
tout au long de leur carrière comme chef
d'exploitation et au niveau smic en
seront donc exclus les collaborateurs
d'exploitation les aides familiaux très
majoritaire marc madame chapa des femmes
sans oublier que cette réforme ne
concerne finalement que les futurs
retraités
quand allez-vous mettre fin à ce cynisme
et à ses effets danos les retraités
agricoles toucher les pensions les plus
faibles du pays
la retraite moyenne comme le dit j'ai
mon collègue d'un chef d'exploitation
après une carrière complète est de 740
euros par mois 550 pour une femme je
vous ai rappelé qu'avant d'être ministre
de l'agriculture didier guillaume avait
été sénateur votre question vous vous
rappelez lui qu'à défaut de pouvoir être
mère il est ministre
ma question quand allez vous
revaloriser les retraites agricoles
merci